we're allowed to shoot at the k9
training unit on the base which was
perfect because well let's face it dogs
love me I'm here in the working dog unit
is that what you call it
military working dog section military
working dog section and this is
technical staff sergeant de Leon Watson
yes guys how you doing done good
okay you're doing good yes sir you train
dogs for military purposes is that right
anything is no go out and take as well
so no drugs oh and not drugs other dogs
I'm gonna be working with today can they
sense drugs I kind of need to know what
about like cialis or viagra would they
be able to detect that in my bloodstream
no okay but I mean a lot of it okay what
about major antidepressants no okay lots
of them have you guys thought of
training cats let me tell you something
I have three cats they're [ __ ]
incredible [ __ ] dogs they get it
right they will defend our country cats
are like masters gerbils I've messed
around with dribbles a bit didn't talk
about it can the dogs detective there's
a gerbil inside me right now I went too
far they've just brought a dog out I
that appears to be a German Shepherd am
I correct yes sir what is your name my
name is senior Airman Dominic singleton
and that's a store yes sir I don't know
if you can understand me but I'll speak
to you now in fake German
Oh Astro just ran through the cool tube
if we ever invade a mini-golf course
we're all set Astro is not giving back
the chew toy Astor is to be
court-martialed Astor has decided to go
AWOL
she's trying to escape now through the
gate and make his way onto a flight back
to Germany
I thought Astor did pretty well I think
I could do better
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we are joined now by Andrew and
gentlemen what is Andrew going to
demonstrate well basically he's gonna
demonstrate he's gonna be the bad guy
he's gonna be the bad guy are you at all
worried than what you're basically doing
is training our dogs to only attack fat
men dressed as hobos you're going to
wear something on your face aren't you
hey you don't worry about the dog biting
your face off no did you know that just
before this next test I'm gonna smear
your cheeks with bacon grease do you
worry at all about the general area
being attacked I've been bit there
before sir yes I mean by a dog I've been
there I need another guy's name the
important thing is you had fun and no
one got anybody's name
gentlemen how am i doing over here am i
killing it kill I'm killing it his suit
can't protect him from my attacks huh
come on up here over tcid how you doing
there how are you hanging in there all
right you go ahead and head back you're
all right there stay actually not come
back over you stay ready check it out I
need more beer I showed you you gotta
understand come back over you know come
over you know little buddy to the other
lease my dog on you you are yes I am it
all right what did you get over here
oh yes that guy was being a dick he was
warned so many times I've done stupid
things yeah I got some ID here you go
what is that okay that's alright alright
can I pull back on my way back it's not
real I know it's not real that's all you
can play this game okay there you go
thanks a lot well no trouble for me I'll
just be on my way all right no problem
from this guy I need you to come back
you want me from back you know I'm just
thinking maybe I should go over there
and get some pie look if you go over
there it's gonna be a bad day for you no
no I really gotta go
well I need you to come over here
otherwise the police my dog I don't
think you want that
oh don't love America
it's funny I the dog just kick the [ __ ]
out of me and I I really love him he's
great he's a great dog so I want to get
me one of those